don't you walk through life but don't
don't say it's all going to be great you
know I'll do this and I'll do that you
know I'm just marking time to be older
that I've told people it's like saving
up sex for your old age I don't have to
do you know following Wall Street is
telling me to do that quarter or
something I got so I own the brush I own
the canvas and the campus is unlimited
defining your circle of competence is
the most important aspect of investing
those says if I'd been born a few
thousand years ago itíd in some animals
lunch because I just go around saying
well I'm allocate capital you know
animals say they're the kind of tastes
the best you know and I can't run fast I
can't climb trees
he's been the chairman and largest
shareholder of Berkshire Hathaway since
1970 his success in investing has led to
people calling him the Oracle or sage of
Omaha he's considered to be the most
successful investor in the world and is
the second wealthiest person in the
world with an estimated net worth of
seventy three point nine billion dollars
he's Warren Buffett and here's my take
on his top ten rule to success volume
two rumor one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the
way to the end for some special bonus
clips also as Lauren is talking if he
says something that is really meaningful
to you please leave it in the comments
below put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
I was just wondering what is what would
you consider to be the worst investment
you've ever made the worst investment I
ever made how long do you have why I've
made some very bad ones but that doesn't
really bother me I am a father the
shareholders but that's another question
yeah see yeah you know you're going to
make you're gonna make mistakes in life
I mean there's no question about it you
don't want to make them on the big
decisions you know who you Marian's and
things like that so there's no way I'm
going to make a lot of business and
investment decisions without making some
mistakes I may try to minimize them I
don't I don't dwell on them at all I
don't that don't look back the biggest
mistakes are the ones that actually
don't show up they're the mistakes of
omission rather than commission we've
never lost that much money on any one
investment but it's the things that I
knew enough to do that I didn't do we've
we have missed profits of as much as you
know maybe 10 billion dollars and things
that I knew enough to do and I didn't do
now the fact I didn't buy microsoft way
back is not a forgone opportunity
because I didn't know enough to make
that decision but there have been other
investments where I did know enough to
make the decision and for one reason or
another I either didn't do it at all or
I did it on a small scale I was sucking
my thumb when I should have been writing
checks you know basically and and and
you know those don't show up there's no
place where it shows missed
opportunities but I've missed some big
ones the triumphs in life are partly
trying to you know that everything isn't
going to be a triumph and and and I
would never get too hung up on mistakes
I know a lot of people that really
agonize over them and it just isn't
worth it I mean tomorrow's another day
and you live it forward just go on to
the next thing
I I advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job I mean you know
don't sleepwalk through life but don't
don't say it's all going to be great you
know I'll do this and I'll do that
you know I'm just marking time going to
be older that I've told people it's like
saving up sex for your old age I mean it
just is not a system in it it is not a
good idea yeah yeah what are you urging
them to do here's what I'm talking about
my it just yeah you really want to be
doing what you love doing and you can't
necessarily find it on your first job
right but don't give up before you find
it what brings you the most satisfaction
beyond family well most criticize back
she's just taking good help and what
you're 86 I look at this a little
liverish yeah so you are you in good
health
oh yeah I mean I enjoy every day I enjoy
and what is it that you enjoy well I do
i running Bircher i mean if you get
right down into my psyche I mean this
what I wanted me I know is it's just you
know it's been my painting for 50 some
years I get to paint what I want I don't
have to I don't have to do you know
follow what Wall Street is telling me to
do that quarter or something like that
so I own the brush I own the canvas and
the campus is on love of it now that's a
that's a pretty nice game and I get to
do it every day with people I like I
don't have to I don't have to associate
with anyone that causes my stomach to
churn you know if I were in politics I'd
have to smile a lot of people but I want
to hit you so I go to them it's really
I've got a good deal on going on do it
I'd like to know we all consider you to
be the financial business experts and we
look to you and follow your lead but
when you need advice and feedback about
an idea or decision I like now who do
you go to well usually I look in the
mirror
the nature what I do means I have to say
pretty much independently because if I
take a poll in effect I'm going to do
what everybody else is doing and I don't
think much of that usually in
investments and so I have to have an
environment and I have to have a temper
but personally that lets me think for
myself
and I've got a terrific partner someone
like Charlie Munger and if you can't
find anybody a smarter any better
quality of anything but we think a lot
alike and we do talk things over
occasionally but we don't talk them over
very often because I know how he thinks
he knows I think he's what he's taught
me a lot you know and and you know why
should I pay for a phone call if I for
you to say so if I need to get a cabinet
around to make decisions or anything
like that I probably shouldn't be
running the place at and that doesn't
bother me to have the responsibility for
but I I just don't want to put it up to
a vote because I've seen too many
pertinent investment world as you get
larger and larger groups making the
decisions they get more and more
modernized and I don't think you will
ever get brilliant investment decisions
out of the large committee I always look
at IQ and talent as sort of representing
the horsepower of the motor but then in
terms of the output the efficiency with
which the motor works that depends on
rationality because a lot of people
start out with four hundred horsepower
motors and get a hundred horsepower of
output and it's way better to have a 200
horsepower motor and get it all and
output and then so why do why do smart
people do things that interfere with
really getting the V and the output
they're entitled to and it's it gets
into the habit from the character into
temper mutton it really gets into
behaving in a rational manner and not
letting not getting in your own way as I
say everybody here has the ability
absolutely to do anything I do and much
beyond and and some of you will and some
of you won't but it will the ones that
won't
because he because you get in your own
way won't because the world doesn't
allow you to it'll it will be because
you don't allow yourself to you will
move in the direction of the people that
you associate with so it's important
associated with people that are better
than yourself and actually the most
important decision many of you may not
all of you will be the spouse you're
choosing and you really you want to
associate with people who are the kind
of person you'd like to be you'll move
in that direction and the most important
person by far in that respect is your
spouse's you I can't overemphasize how
important that is you're right the
friends you have they will form you as
you go through life and make some good
friends keep them for the rest of your
life but have them be people that you
admire as well as like them passion
believes that I can only should expect
to make money and things that I
understand and when I say understand I
don't understand it you know what the
product does or anything like that I
mean understand what the economics of
the business are likely to look at look
like ten years of our 20 years ago I
know in general what the economic so say
Wrigley chewing gum will look like ten
years now the internet isn't going to
change the way people chew gum it isn't
going to change which gum they chew now
if you own the chewing gum market in a
big way and you've got double mint
spearmint and juicy fruit those brands
will be there and here's Nelson I can't
pinpoint exactly what the numbers are
going to look like on Wrigley but I'm
not going to be way off if I try to look
forward on something like that that
evaluating that company is within what I
call my circle of competence I
understand what they do I understand the
economics of it I understand the
competitive aspects of the business so
figuring out the economic consequences
TV
I think there's I don't know 20 25
million sensei years old the United
States I don't think there's one of them
mainly I'd stays anymore
I mean it's a tv-set manufacturer what a
wonderful business which everybody and
nobody on a TV in 1950 they're they're
about 45 to 50
everybody has multiple sons now nobody
in the United States has made any real
money making the since they're all out
of business
you know the Magnavox as the RCA's all
of those companies radio was the
equivalent between over 500 companies
making radios in the 1920s again I don't
think there's a u.s. radio manufacturer
at the present time but coca-cola you
know I was at 1884 and shakings pharmacy
or whatever and still comes up with
something a lot of copiers over the
years but now you've got a company that
is selling roughly 1.1 billion eight
ounce servings of its product not all
cokes right and some others daily
throughout the world 117 years later so
understanding the economic
characteristics of the business is
different than predicting the fact that
an industry is going to do wonderfully
so I look at the internet businesses or
look at tech misses I think this is a
marvelous thing and I love to play
around on the computer and I ordered my
books from Amazon and all kinds of
things but I don't know who's going to
win unless I know it's going to win I'm
not interested in the best thing I'll
just play around on the computer
defining your circle of competence is
the most important aspect of investing
it's not how important how large your
circle is you don't have to be an expert
on everything but knowing where the
perimeter of that circle of what you
know on what you don't know is and
staying inside of it is all important
Tom Watson seniors start at IBM said in
his book he said it I know genius that
but I'm smart in spots I stay around
those spots
you know that is the key so if I
understand a few things and I speak in
that arena I'll do okay and if I don't
understand something I get all excited
about it because my neighbors are
talking about and stocks are going up
everything they started fooling around
someplace else eventually I'll get
creamed and I should well in 1973 the
Washington Post Company gone public in
1971 right about the Pentagon Papers
type time but in 73 the Nixon
administration was through bebe rebozo
was a pal of Nixon's they were
challenging the licenses of two of the
Florida television stations to post own
so the stock went from 37 down to 16 now
at 16 there were about five million
shares outstanding so the whole
Washington Post company was something
for 80 million dollars and that included
the newspaper for big TV stations
Newsweek and some other assets and no
debt to speak of so the Washington Post
Company which was intrinsically worth
four or five hundred million dollars was
selling for about 80 million in the
market we'd bought most of our stock at
about the equivalent of a hundred
million in the market and and it was it
was ridiculous I mean you had a business
unquestionably was worth four or five
times what was selling for and Nixon
wasn't going to put them out of business
when you're doing these analyses then
and now do you have computers that help
you or how did you actually read all
what you get to get pretty materials or
how to do it in those days get the
materials to read about the Washington
Post and how do you do it today well
same pretty much the same way except
there's fewer opportunities now but I
met Bob Woodward back and and he'd just
come out with all the presidents man oh
and all of a sudden is that all thirty
years of a she was getting quite wealthy
we had we had breakfast or lunch over at
the Madison Hotel I said what do I do
with this money and I said I said
investing is just about assigning
yourself the right story I said imagine
Ben Bradlee this morning said to you
what is the washington post company
worth what would you do if you have to
write the story in a month you'd go out
and interview TV brokers and newspaper
brokers and the owners and it's a client
value each asset I said that's what I do
I assign myself the right story and it's
nothing more than that now there are
some stories I can't write if you ask me
to write a story on you know what is
some grammars but non profit making
business worth I don't know how to write
that story but if you asked me to write
a story on what is Potomac Electric
power or something like that I can write
the story and that's what I'm doing
every day I'm assigning myself a story
and then I go out and one thing I will
tell you that I didn't realize when I
was getting out of school is how much
the unusual person
will jump out at you I mean you know and
it isn't because they got 200 IQs or
anything like that it's really because
just how they behave you know what they
bring the energy they bring the
commitment they bring the quality of how
they do things how they treat the people
around them all kinds of things but you
will jump out much more than you might
anticipate one of the things you would
want to be sure to do is whether you
like it or not get very comfortable it
may take a while the public speaking for
example I mean that that's a an asset
that will last you 50 or 60 years and
it's a liability if you don't like doing
it or uncomfortable doing it that also
will ask you 50 or 60 years and it's a
necessary skill but a lot of the skills
are just human skills if you get the
best out of people around you that's a
rare talent and it doesn't it doesn't
correlate what IQ it correlates with a
you know an attitude and that is going
toward the world and toward other people
and it's the talent that if you work at
early they're really conscious about it
you know you don't have to show up other
people you know you're not very smart in
there or anything you want to bring out
the best in them it will pay huge
dividends I went one-on-one with lebron
a few years ago and we had a jump ball
and LeBron went up he got he got the tip
what's the length of the core court
dunked it and just then turned around
and just then I was jumping like that's
not I got lucky
bill says if I'd been born a few
thousand years ago added in some animals
lunch because I just go around saying
well I
allocate capital you know and
yeah we'll say there's a God to taste
the best at all I can't run fast I can't
climb trees you don't need a lot of
brains in this business I mean I've
always said if you got an IQ of 160 give
away 30 points or somebody else because
you don't need it in investments what
you do need is emotional stability I've
got a partner Charlie Berger says he
admires humility enormous Lee but it
wasn't quite given this fair share you
know we we call on people that have a
billion or more at least details as they
do and all we asked is 50% so if you
know if you can't if you have trouble
living on 500 million I'm going to put
out a book how to live on five hundred
million dollars I don't think I can win
every game you know somebody said how do
you beat Bobby Fischer you play in any
game except chess so I don't play Bobby
Fischer let's do it here you know the
end is near and so I face the final
curtain my friend I'll say it clear
statements or something around which I'm
certain turning on I've lived a life of
small traveled each and every Highway
and more much more than this I did it
so much for watching I made this video
because a lot of you enjoyed the Warren
Buffett top ten rules of success Volume
one so there's someone who you really
enjoyed the volume one up and you want
us to do a volume to let me know leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do
I'd also love to know what is war and
say that has the biggest impact on you
what lesson are you going to take from
this and immediately apply it to your
life or to your business leave in the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out finally I want to give a quick shout
out to Riza pereira Riza thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and sharing that picture
with me I really really really really
appreciate it
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
capital management I hope most of you
are familiar with it the whole story is
really fascinating because if you take
John Meriwether and Eric Rosenfeld Larry
Hill and branch Greg Hawkins victory
Ghani the two Nobel Prize winners and
Merton Scholes if you take the 16 of
them they thought we have as high an
average IQ as any 16 people working
together in one business in the country
including at Microsoft or wherever you
want a name so there's incredible amount
of intellect in that room now you
combine that with the fact that those 16
and had extensive experience in the
field they're operating I mean this one
it was not a bunch of guys who had made
their money you know selling men's
clothing and all of a sudden one into
the securities business or anything they
had they'd had in aggregate the 16 that
probably had 350 or 400 years of
experience doing exactly what they were
doing and then you throw in the third
factor that most of them had virtually
all of their very substantial networks
in the business so they had their own
money up hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars of their own money
up super high intellect working in a
field they knew and essentially they
went broke and that to me is absolutely
fascinating I mean I did it I ever write
a book it's going to be called why smart
people do dumb things my partner says it
should be autobiographical but I but
this might be an interesting
illustration and these are perfectly
decent guys III respect them and I
helped me out when I was at problems
with Salomon and so that they're they're
not bad people at all but to make money
they didn't have and didn't need they
risked what they did have and did need
and that's foolish that is just plain
foolish I put my gamer switch your IQ is
if you if you risk something that is
important to you for something that is
unimportant to you it just does not make
any sense I don't care whether the odds
are a hundred to one that you succeed or
a thousand wonders succeed if you hand
me a gun with a thousand chambers out a
million chambers in it and there's a
bullet in one chamber and use that put
it up your temple how much do you want
to be paid to pull it once
I'm not going to pull it you know you
can name any sum you want but it doesn't
do
for me on the upside and I think the
downside fairly clear so I'm not
interested in that kind of a game and
yet people do it financially then
without thinking about it very much
generally speaking investing in yourself
is the best thing you can do anything
that improves your own talent say nobody
can take it away from me they can run up
huge deficits and the dollar can become
worth far less you can have all kinds of
things happen but if you've got talents
yourself and you've maximized your
talent
you've got a terrific asset and that
does mean everybody should go to college
but it it doesn't mean that any way you
find to improve communication skills are
enormously important I mean I took the
Dale Carnegie course that I paid on
dollars for and it was worth a college
degree at least I thought it was this
interview will consume a lot of lies